success happens when we sign off on a  finished thing and say okay send it out  into the world that's the moment of  success because that's the only part I  have any participation in that's the  only part I can control everything else  is based on market conditions on stars  aligning many of the people whose music  came out on 911 their music got lost and  their careers never recovered just  because it happened to come out on 9 11.  and that's out of everyone's control  that's again it's it's Universal  intervention we don't know how it works  watching these occurrences  sometimes they're good sometimes they're  bad and thinking of it as riding a wave  the universe is pushing us in a  direction and we can ride with that  energy and like when you're surfing if  you really try to fight the wave it's  probably not going to work we try to use  the power of the wave where we're almost  dancing with the wave not not against  the wave